no way holy what is that script
there's a champion in League of Legends
that cheaters love more than any other
zerath there's 164 Champions to choose
from in League of Legends but something
about this Champion that was released
over 12 years ago is just irresistible
to cheaters and here's
[Music]
why League of Legends is not a perfect
game it does have its problems but one
of them isn't really cheating in 2018
Riot shared statistics on the prevalence
of cheating in ranked showing a downward
Trend over the previous two years to a
rate of less than
0.5% of all games they also said the
average player is likely to encounter a
scripter once in every 400 ranked games
now that's not bad when you compare it
to the likes of Counter Strike valve
haven't released their official cheating
stats but the overwhelming anecdotal
evidence over the years points to the
fact that it's probably a lot worse than
one in 400 games but although scripting
isn't a major problem in League of
Legends it does still exist and scripts
can come in many forms some of them
track information the player probably
wouldn't know otherwise super super
zoomed out which is and like it gives
him all info like every CD flash
Summoners CS what they leveled up first
um just so much info honestly it's like
info overload if I if I played like this
immediately I would actually probably
initially play a little worse this is
info overload some help a player Dodge
skill shots better than
Faker hell no hell no hey someone check
this PC man some of them are used to
maximize mechanically intensive
Champions like
copia oh that was instantaneous like
instantaneous you see that both spells
activated at the exact time and she hit
it dead in the center of where she was
going to be that's actually a script and
AD carry Champions tend to attract
scriptors too due to the ability to orw
walk kite and Dodge like an AI skills
that traditionally separate an average
ad carry from an absolutely cracked one
but there's one Champion that is
synonymous with scripting One champion
that comes to mind for everyone when
they think of scripting in League One
champion that honestly kind of seems
designed almost for scripting Zera in
League like you actually do have a
decent chance of beating someone who's
cheating their ass off like look at
this what
what wow the script can immediately
track LeBlanc W look at that amazing
over the years it's reached a point
where a lot of players are immediately
suspicious of a good zerath player when
most players pull off a Perfect combo
and land all their abilities to get a
kill they're a god when an honest Zera
does it they usually accuse Des
scripting so how did things end up like
this for zerath well like many things it
all begins with champion design Riot
designed zerath as an artillery Champion
he's supposed to sit behind his team
poke down the enemy from a distance and
finish off Strikers with his ult in
order to balance the relative safety of
zeras long range abilities RI also made
them pretty hard to hit he's balanced
around the fact that the average player
is probably going to miss some of their
skill shots so when they do land they
need to hit a bit harder to compensate
but whatever player was hitting 80% 90%
95% of all of their Zera skill shots
consistently suddenly those skill shots
don't seem so balanced they seem a
little
unfair that guy C this is this guy nope
nope nope I can't I can't play scripting
turns there as from a champion that is
pretty balanced because it's expected
that you're with a certain amount of
skill shots to one that is insanely
broken because you never really miss and
this is even stronger on Zera than you
might think because in League of Legends
zerath is kind of the skill shot King
out of all 164 champions in League of
Legends there are very few that actually
have four offensive skill shots as their
abilities velos has four Lux has four
but one of them is a shield you could
also include corki tiia zigs it kind of
depends on where you draw the line on
what is an offensive skill shot now
don't get me wrong you can find examples
of scripting on dozens of different
Champions there really aren't many
champions that scripting doesn't improve
maybe except UD it's just that there are
some like zerath who take it to a whole
new level on top of the sheer amount of
damage skill shots that zerath has his
qw and R go through minions which Mak
scripting on him a lot easier as you
don't have to worry about your skill
shots being blocked like you would with
other Champions so zerath becomes the
obvious choice for a lot of scriptors he
has not one not two not three but four
damaging abilities three of which cannot
be blocked and as we established earlier
become extremely broken when you're able
to hit most of them like a scriptor can
so we know why scripts work well on Zera
and when you watch a scriptor playing
Zera it becomes pretty obvious why
they're so attracted to him there's
plenty of vods uploaded by scriptors
that show how his skill shots are raided
by scripts in this clip you can see the
scriptor Quee lock on to Garen despite
the players cursor being nowhere near
him look at that absolutely nowhere near
him in this YouTube VOD modestly titled
how I won every single game scripting on
zerath look at how every cast of zerath
alt hits despite his cursor being
nowhere near an enemy netting him a
double kill that would make a challenger
player blush will scriptors always be
drawn to zerah zero was released in 2011
and hasn't really changed too much since
you'd expect that at some point over the
past decade there would have been a few
champions release that would be better
suited for scripting than him but that's
not necessarily always been the case we
spoke to former Riot game security Dev
theander M magic about how Riot may have
shifted aspects of their game design
philosophy in response to scripting you
know it's easy to look back at it and be
like yeah okay A Champion that's this
mechanically intense and requires this
amount of like Perfection to really
excel in yeah this going to be
scriptable like someone's going to write
Automation and destroy people and uh I
think that uh you know as as these
things pop up I think game developers at
least RI has been very receptive and has
changed Champion kits to make it easier
so that uh people aren't abusing scripts
to actually be good at those Champions
making it easier for a player to
maximize a Champions kit means there's
less room for scripts to exist in the
first place it lowers the whole skill
ceiling so that scripting doesn't give
as much of an advantage as it would
would with a champion like Zera that's
not to say that more modern Champions
like Cante Gwen or rework to Cari have
overloaded kits that probably need
adjusting but a scriptor isn't going to
be able to squeeze that much more juice
out of them in a way they could with
zerth now not long after we spoke to
nenja R announced new Champion Hai the
champion has a whopping 10 abilities the
most unique abilities on One champion in
League's history and one which Riot have
already admitted has a high skill
ceiling and High complexity so it's not
too surprising that there's already been
scripts developed for him with players
looking to abuse his inherent complexity
and maximize his potential to levels he
was never balanced around could ha be
the new Zera possibly but it's hard to
beat zerath as the cheaters Champion for
the reasons we've already gone over it
would probably take a rework for him to
be less appealing to scriptors but the
issue is he really doesn't need a rework
when you step back and look at the big
picture his win rate tends to hover at
or above 50% his popularity can range
between 5 and 10% depending on the patch
and his band rate is currently sitting
at a very modest 14% these are all
respectable numbers it's unlikely that
Riot will make zerath less skill shot
dependent in order to lower the
effectiveness of scripts on him it's
just not worth it as we said at the top
of the video League of Legends has an
acceptably low level of cheating
relative to other games and even though
scripting does inflate a player win rate
it's not the be all and end all I would
say that the nice thing though about
League of Legends is it's a team based
game to the point that even if someone's
cheating with scripts you can still win
a lot of the times against them it's not
as uh lethal as like an FPS game where
you know someone aimbotting an attack
shooter just completely carries their
team right and you have zero recourse
there you just lose the round and
eventually the entire match it's likely
the will continue to use other
preventative measures to keep scriptors
out of League instead of tearing up a
champion like zerath zerath is fine
zerath is a great Champion even he just
happens to be the one in League of
Legends that cheaters probably love most
I've just been handed this by producer
Matt you probably recognize this as uh
Jinx and um we're giving this away to
the person who comments first in the
video don't even have to know your
address I'm kidding of course
please don't sue us just a little joke